a rough week for the banking industry
the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank the
second biggest bank collapse in U.S
history the Silicon Valley Bank
collapsed on March 10 after a run on
deposits doomed the tech-focused
lender's plans to raise fresh Capital
this prompted U.S Regulators to step in
with emergency measures including
seizing another bank three days later in
a bid to ease fears that depositors
might pull their money from other
lenders wsj banking reporter Rachel
Ensign explains how this crisis unfolded
and what could happen next
during the pandemic Silicon Valley Bank
had gotten all of these deposits their
deposits tripled it was a huge huge huge
influx and they did what banks do they
took some of the deposits and made loans
but they also invested a lot of them in
Securities which are pretty safe some
issues had been bubbling under the
surface at Silicon Valley Bank since the
Federal Reserve started raising rates
when rates Rose the bonds fell in value
it's not a big problem for you unless
you have to go and sell the bonds but
deposits started leaving the bank faster
than they anticipated and they had to
sell their bonds and take a very big
loss the bank made an announcement on
Wednesday night that it needed to raise
capital and was planning to do that the
next day the investors completely
freaked out sold off the stock and then
a bank run started where people tried to
withdraw 42 billion dollars in deposits
just in that one day and by Friday
morning it was seized by Regulators The
Regulators have responded in a way that
they're hoping stems the Panic the FED
said we're going to be offering this
lending facility that's a backstop we're
going to be ensuring all of the deposits
effectively of this bank that failed
foreign
the collapse matters because it could
have broader economic effects there was
the risk that this Panic would spread to
other parts of the banking system we saw
some really significant news with some
of the banks that investors were most
concerned about last week most notable
Signature Bank a new york-based bank was
also seized on Sunday night it is the
third largest bank failure in U.S
history and First Republic put out a
statement saying they had gotten some
extra money from the Federal Reserve and
also from JPMorgan they're hoping that
that reassures their investors and their
depositors
[Music]
the key thing to watch for is is the
panic over that's the big question do
people stop pulling their money out do
investors and customers kind of are they
reassured in the way that the government
would like them to be